Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number that you can
call. That number is two one nine two. David P.
Here is again a caller continuing to
accuse me of suppressing the truth.
About what? It's not even clear.
I think he's referring to covid
because that's what he's always referring to.
Speaker 6: There was help given its error from
Mass again, he loved to make fun of my accent.
How are you doing, man? Why? I just wanted to say,
with all the stuff coming out that you're
suppressing, it's only two options here. And
this is good. Either you're too stupid
to realize this or you're in on it. And,
buddy, I would never call you stupid.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you know, one of the
really I mean, there's a lot of sad stuff here,
typically when this guy calls in, he'll refer
to something like, David, you're covering up that
millions of people have died from the vaccine or
something like that. And it's like, no, I'm not
covering that up. That's not real. But there's
this other really weird thing that's being lodged
at people who just like report the science about
what's going on with the virus and vaccines,
which is they they suggest that, you know what
I by saying I'm in on it, what exactly would I be
in on what advantage would there be to me? Like,
no, no, no, there's no financial advantage
to just telling the truth about the vaccines.
There's no personal advantage other than yes,
it's true. If more people get vaccinated,
I'm safer and people I know are safer. Part of the
conspiracy that assumes that, you know, this idea
of complicit in lying about the vaccines and covid
is that there would be some advantage conferred by
it. And of course, they can never really explain
what that advantage is. But no, nothing is being
covered up. And by the way, when, when and some
upcoming show, increasingly people are pointing to
the Veirs system press and saying, look at all of
these reports of people who died from the vaccine
in the Veirs system. I'm thinking of doing a video
where I actually I'll show you on a screen share.
I'll go through the VA system and show you how
easy it is to just say my brother died from the
vaccine and submit it. And of course, it's not
Czech. I wouldn't actually submit it. I would
just show you how easy it would be to do this is
what people are doing. People are submitting bogus
reports to the Veirs system. And then those bogus
reports are being used by anti vaccine individuals
and media outlets and pointed to and said, look at
all of these reports. Anybody can submit a report.
There's no checking whatsoever that is done on the
bonus show today. We will talk about remember that
Missouri couple of lawyers who were waving guns
last June during the Black Lives Matter protests.
They both pleaded guilty to misdemeanors. They've
been pardoned by the Missouri governor. Yeah,
the McCluskey's. We'll talk about that on the
bonus show. Secondly, we appear to be between
two and five weeks away from FDA full approval
of the coronavirus vaccine made by Pfizer. Will
this really get some of these anti vaccines
vaccinated? I don't know. We're going to talk
about it. And lastly, the Japanese government
is starting a program of publicly naming people
who are breaking quarantine rules in Japan. Is
this a good idea? Could it lead to disaster?
What would happen if the United States did it? All
of those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Sign up and get instant access by making yourself
a member at Join Pakman dot com. I'll speak to the